[Musique]
OK
onte
l'
[Musique]
er je mon un truc
coup il dans son
trucett dans jardit
Heach
intéressant pe
jardin va revenir chercher de
l'eau
là il revient chercher de l'eau
voilà VO bien son chemin
[Musique]
d'ailleurs
va remettre de l'eau
là-bas
voilà général
deaction est en plan
large
il sarrêté ah de merde attends
attends il va y aller il va y aller il
va y aller
attends j'ai pas entendue un peu la
parce que moi mon cadrage tu vois après
j'ai les trucs Remon un petit voilà
voilà
voilà l'au on s'enf voilà voilà on a
l'action hop il est parti à son on le
laisse faire ça en large après je le
prend
est-ce qu'il tire comment il le tire
d'ailleurs faire un geste
Dee pas
o il la ceour du
coup de la
taille ah c'est une PPE c'est une pompe
non non il va chercher l'eau avec une
core avec une pas du
toutond le saut toc
il est pas très
profondre bon pour le dos
ça
dans T les jardin des g c'est incroyable
partout partout
part l' c'est la
vie j'imagine que tu l'
sort
ok vous en faites un ou deux autres
jolis attends il y en a
tour
vraiment à
côté la
douche
Jol j petit
jardin un peu conf ton
truc
allez
arrilà pied un peu à gauche
ça tout petit peu pied à gauche merci
c'est joli petit
gin petit
rond
croyez
que plus devant c'est joli
ai tu ver un
peu un peu devant toiU en c'est joli ok
coupe dis-moi ceux qui sont juste dans
qui son allez
tourne c'est super beau ça large hein
ouis c'est ça rentre bien dedans voilà
les plein
cadres prends pas prends pas trop de
sable à droite voilà si tu pouvais
oui
pas comment
tourn pas comme ça voil voil voilà j
voil commuc je dis pas bien
pas
ah de merde que ça rien rien
c'est moi qui
merde
des
coupe c'est joli
ça il à gauche ou pas du tout Fran ils
sont tous là non il y en a un autre à
gauche
je dégage un peu
tu as raison c'est bien de faire ça
ou rapproche pas trop he de de T les
tous que je puisse travailler ave ma
focale ouais mais je tout droit là non
ok ok ok je pas dis-moi dis-moi voà
promène-toi là-dedans c'est joli ça
j'aime bien moi ça tu
vois comme ça jusqu'au jardin ouais par
exoua
ouais c'est Jon c'est bien on a pas fait
ça encore on l'IT pas
fait de film ça ah ouais tu peux tourner
un
film ma droite hein en tout droit ok
d'accord merci vas-y
écl-toi voilà pas trop vite pas trop
vites pr
temps vend ok ok ok ok ok pas de souci
vasy vasy vas-y
cette découverte des ça c'est les PL que
j'adore
ça on se promène comme ça on est un
peu en voil VO beaucoup de comm ça
découvre
là là
là est
quoi
coupe
joli
ça bien dans la matière en plus que
j'
Vy avance moi je
récupore
la droite pas trop à gauche le dernier
le là-bas queas dans le cadre c'est le
dernier c'est très bien vachement USTR
c'est
super super super super les enfants
c'est vachement
bien
c'est joli c'est joli en plus regarde
regarde Collin et tout c'est super beau
ça
voilà tu es loin dis la vache je
comprends comprais pas du tout tu étais
allez
arrête-toi je su
excuse-moiuse jqu si on va se poser plus
de Carau du tout
2 allez coupe c'est bon for merf